bonsoir aulas quelle est la situation
sanitaire actuellement en israël
ribeauvillé se fait comme suit est après
les derniers chiffres dont nous
disposons il ya deux jours nous
enregistrons chaque jour en moyenne 8000
nouveaux cas de co vide parmi ces
nouveaux cas
de 64 70 personnes autant de
sérieusement malade ce qui est tout
particulièrement préoccupant c'est une
large partie de ces cas surviennent
parmi la jeunesse nous avons connu une
tendance descendante pendant un certain
temps en israël mais elle s'est inversée
et le ministère de la santé se prépare
dès à présent pour une heure 5e vav
nous faisons face la plus importante
vague de contaminations qu'israël ait
connu à ce jour il ya également beaucoup
de
discussions sur le système du passeport
vers
le passeport vert est maintenu pour les
semaines et mois à venir
évidemment on se pose la question on en
parlait justement avec ce docteur
français il y à il y à quelques minutes
des contaminations
malgré l'injection de vax ans et c'est
bien ça mais peut-être pas de forme
grave c'est bien ça aussi
c'est
hier que la nouvelle victime du nouveau
vaccin les chiffres semblent indiquer
qu'elle est efficace cette vaccination
d'après le centre médical tel hashomer
de tel aviv la troisième dose est encore
plus efficace qu'on ne le pensait elle
génère des niveaux d'anticorps dans le
corps jusqu'à 10 fois plus élevées des
niveaux d'anticorps après le second
vaccin en israël 3 millions d'israéliens
ont reçu leur troisième dose
maccabi qui est un programme sanitaire
de santé en lancera elle a établi que le
vaccin est efficace à 86% contre
l'apparition de lakovic pour les
personnes de plus de 60 ans c'est le
côté positif
du côté négatif les tendances montrent
toujours hélas encore beaucoup de
questions notamment pour les personnes
une sur cinq quasiment qui ont choisi de
ne pas se vacciner
65 %
de toutes les formes graves de
coronavirus apparaissent parmi à cette
population non vaccinée naftali bennett
le premier ministre israélien ainsi que
la population à se faire vacciner
mais comme je les 10 17 % des israéliens
refusent toujours
israël s'apprête on a lu dans la presse
aujourd'hui à dégainer la grosse
artillerie technologique et a annoncé la
mise en place pour la d'un système
surnommé oméga capable de réaliser des
des scanners génétique qu'en est il
exactement
on est encore au stade préliminaire
il est piloté par le premier ministre
israëlien ap tony bennett et développer
car on redoute que les futurs vague de
coronavirus arriveront en israël depuis
les airs
comme est arrivé le variante lta alors
que le pays réussissait à endiguer la
maladie
depuis des mois les aéroports sont donc
restés fermés et on va lancer un
programme pilote plus tard dans l'année
qui permettra à des gens ne se rendre en
israël à s'ils ont été vaccinées deux
fois et s'ils ont été testés dans les 48
heures avant leur arrivée
ce programme qui comme vous l'avez
mentionné s'appelle programme eau mega
permet à à leur arrivée à l'aéroport de
ben gourion la porte principale à tel
aviv d'être
scanner de créer un séquençage génétique
afin de vérifier si
il y à présence de variants ou de formes
du corps navires us
car on doute que le prochain variant
pourrait arriver via les trajets aériens
le programme donc pas encore en place
mais devrait l'être très bientôt
merci paul à slayer en direct de
tel-aviv merci d'avoir été